so as we get into our video of Secret
Wars part 8 what we're going to do here
is tie the events of previous issues
into our discussion which should allow
for a smooth continuation of the story
so far but also cover any questions you
might have along the way so in the
previous issue we had talked about how
following the death of dr. strange and
the dispersing of the earth-616 and
ultimate universe heroes and villains
across battle world that over the course
of several weeks these various
individuals had found their way into
several camps including Jane Foster and
the Thor core Carol Danvers and mr.
sinister and so on however these various
threats all came together when Maximus
the mad the inhuman brother of Black
Bolt began amassing an army to lead a
revolution against doom picking up in
the midst of the battle with the Hulk's
Madalyn priors demons and senators
clones the story shifts his focus to
Reed Richards from earth-616 Reed from
The Ultimate Universe and Peter quill
with a group intended to use the battle
as a distraction to sneak into Castle
doom without anyone noticing the trio
set upon by one of the hoax from
maestro's army where the actions of this
particular Hulk result and the engines
being destroyed what this does is set up
for the future encounter between 6-1-6
Reed and the rest of his family from
here we jump to my show at Castle doom
and his attempts to draw out the good
doctor however in the midst of his rant
he's met with the arrival of Ben Grimm
now in one of our previous videos we
discussed how Thanos had discovered that
the shield separating the Ultron robots
the zombies and the annihilation wave
from the rest of battle world was
actually Ben Grimm himself where we
learned that Ben's role as the wall was
a ploy by doom to essentially force him
out of the picture and allow the
indoctrination of Susan storm Franklin
Richards and Valeri Richards when Thanos
had revealed the truth of his life prior
to the collapse of the multiverse been
abandoned his role as the shield
allowing Thanos to muster his own army
and so what this section brings to us is
the final stop of Ben's journey and that
because he's seeking revenge against
doom he's effectively taking out
everyone that he perceives to be in his
way including the maestro furthermore
where Susan storm recognizes who Ben is
while he served as the wall doomed used
that time to modify her memories and
lead her to believe as she had always
been married to doom and the Franklin
and valaria were his children to this
end Susan viewed Ben as a family friend
who may had fought alongside when they
first gained their powers but to her
mind Reed's never existed
now during this time we also see the
return of Terrax the enlightened for
those of you who never saw my videos on
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers care
actually enlightened was a Herald of
Galactus from another reality where the
Illuminati of iron man Black Bolt Reed
Richards Doctor Strange and name on the
Submariner attempted to save the earth
in the midst of an incursion they had
also imprisoned hair acts in the main
Marvel Universe where he escaped
alongside Thanos during the multiversal
collapse and so his appearance here
marks only a handful of times that he's
actually shown up but this appearance
here is really just the result of his
efforts to ally himself with Galactus
now Galactus within the context of
battle world is a little confusing and
hasn't been fully fleshed out by hickman
on one hand he seems to be under the
control of Franklin Richards but whether
this is truly a version of Galactus
being controlled or simply a construct
of Franklin using his ability to work
reality is unknown the only thing we
really know here is that Terrax is
considered an enemy of doom and as such
Franklin simply kills him as Ben Grimm
watches on and so with Ben stepping in
to fight Franklin the battle between the
two of them is actually pretty even
because this is largely a physical fight
the indication here is that even if this
is Galactus simply under the control of
Franklin the full measure of his powers
and controlling all things has been
severely diminished in addition to this
where Susan pleads with doom to step and
since any of this conflict is well
within his abilities he actually chooses
not to the reason why is revealed when
Thanos arrives with the annihilation
horde decide to act for a second the
annihilation horde or the annihilation
wave as was called prior to Secret Wars
is actually something that we haven't
really talked about before
led by being named Annihilus the
annihilation wave first appeared during
the annihilation storyline and came with
analysis attempt to wipe out all life in
the main Marvel Universe where his
attempts were unsuccessful and the story
ended with his defeat at some point
during the collapse of the multiverse
the annihilation wave was collected by
doom and housed on battleworld although
we never actually see this happen
something to also take note of here is
that during the fight between Ben and
Franklin Ben learns that the Franklin's
mind
he and Valyria are the children of susan
and doom stopping the fight and taking a
few moments to focus on this subject the
full extent of Ben's understanding of
the world around him comes into play
where the actions of doom modifying the
memories of Susan Franklin and valaria
goes deeper than he expected
in addition to this because Susan was
such an intricate part of his life and
he has no desire to fight her son VIN
stands down but rather than Franklin
doing the same
he actually destroys Ben now switching
back to Susan and valaria and our
previous videos we discussed how
Valeria's intelligence allowed her to
piecemeal the evidence together leading
her to realize that her memories in
relation to doom were a lie working to
uncover the truth regarding what
happened to her father between the
collapse of the multiverse and the start
of secret wars while Valyria is still
piecing things together from her
perspective this all seems to be a show
by doom and an effort to continue his
deceit and control over battle world and
so coming to the conclusion that Susan
should be made aware of what's going on
Valyria intends to bring her mother to
the location of Owen Reese so that he
can inform her of the truth and
everything that's actually going on
transitioning back to Star Lord in the
midst of his repair of the ship in order
to ensure that he and the reeds can
escape once their mission is finished
he's met with the arrival of Black Swan
now again her character is one of many
women during the multiverse of collapse
who went by the name Black Swan and
served doom and his efforts to kill off
the multiversal versions of Owen Reese
but following the great collapse she had
escaped alongside Thanos and eventually
made her way to doom after the survivors
of the Year 626 and ultimate universe
were dispersed across battle world and
so because Black Swan served doom with
unwavering loyalty prior to the end of
the multiverse during Secret Wars and on
battle world she serves with the same
level of loyalty now where Peter talks a
good talk because Black Swan has
super-strength telepathy Flight and
several other abilities star-lord is
outclassed in virtually every way and so
back into a corner and with seemingly
nowhere to go Peter makes a last-ditch
move by revealing a single splinter of
wood doing it at the tree of Idris Hill
from the remains of Asgard it's revealed
that the splinter was the last surviving
piece of Groot merging itself with the
world tree Groot effectively reforms and
in the process destroys the whole of
Castle doom now switching back to the
battle and the arrival of Thanos with
the annihilation horn the confrontation
between himself and doom is actually
pretty short here what Hickman does is
continued to build on the arrogance of
doom and that to him the entire scheme
of fan OHS and collecting the
annihilation horde was a waste since
doom does not consider them to be of any
importance in addition to this doom is
under the impression that Thanos can be
bought and that doom offers to make him
the
of the waste beyond the wall assuming
that he stands down and walks away
however founds himself also holds hubris
and that he makes the case that where he
once held absolute power in the form of
the Infinity Gauntlet rather than using
it for his own personal desires he used
to sit his judge for all things in
existence now to be honest fathoms is
actually telling a bold-faced lie here
while his time with the Infinity
Gauntlet did see him usurp the role of
eternity as a Supreme Being in the
universe the entire basis behind his
acquisition of power came from the
desire to please mistress of death and
so where there may be truth to what it
is that he's saying here the actual fact
is that when digging a little deeper
Santos's motivation for the Infinity
Gauntlet was completely human and that
he was rooted in the pursuit of love and
so where he makes the argument that he
doesn't need an infinity golem to take
out doom this claim proves to be a false
one when doom seizes Thanos and
completely disintegrates him now if I
can be a little dangerous here I think
Hickman is actually setting the stage
for the return of mistress death the
reason being because as a physical
embodiment of what it means to die she
was the only cosmic entity that couldn't
be killed when the beyonders began the
conquest of wiping out all life well I'm
probably wrong about this at the very
least I think the death of Thanos will
go towards something bigger since this
seems to be too much of a throw away for
a Hickman story and so as this issue
comes to an end following the death of
Thanos the battlefield is met with the
opening of the seed courageous with
zombies pouring in from the Gateway
because the Marvel zombies are able to
infect anyone with the zombie plague
regardless of what power they possess
the immediate reaction is one of fear
and that everyone could easily be
converted if they were infected but the
mastermind behind these actions is
revealed when black panther makes his
presence known while wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet setting the stage for
the confrontation in the end of Doom and
Secret Wars issue number 9
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know what you guys think about the
secret war story so far you guys
enjoying it are you guys looking forward
to it ending because I know I am and I
will catch you guys later peace